Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week’s
Doctor Who Episode Mummy on the Orient Express
brought back a famous british comedian, featured
pop star Foxes and explained the Clara situation.
The way things ended was very controversial
but we can talk about that as we dig through
everything.
Just a reminder, the giveaway is regenerating
again this week.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Starting with Top 5 Moments.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...here we go.
Number 5 - Foxes Is a Traincar Lounge Singer
I’m not a huge Foxes fan or anything, but
I love that she was singing Freddy Mercury.
It was Queen’s “Don’t Stop Me Now”
to be precise, very appropriate for a story
set on a train.
There have been a lot of famous people guest
starring on Doctor Who this year.
I don’t mind seeing familiar faces as long
as they don’t derail the story.
Foxes turned out to
be one of the holograms, so she vanished part
of the way through the episode.
So if you didn’t like her you only had to
deal with it for a little bit.
Number 4 - Frank Skinner is the Chief Engineer
This was a bit of a twist, in real life, for
anyone who doesn’t know, Skinner is a Comedian.
But he wasn’t playing an overtly comedic
role in the episode.
If you watched the Five-ish Doctors Special
during the 50th Anniversary, he also had a
cameo in that as a Dalek Operator.
I really like it when comedians are given
the chance to do something more dramatic.
Everyone needs to watch Eddie Izzard on Hannibal
Season 1 if you haven’t seen it yet.
Comedians are inherently dark people, so that
might be why they’re so good at playing
dramatic characters.
Skinner’s first run in with The Doctor was
probably one of the funniest moments in the
episode.
He did seem like a match for wits and he even
knew how to repair the TARDIS.
I feel like that bit with him at the end,
talking about how to fix things, raised more
questions than it answered.
And the bit about The Doctor offering him
a spot on board as a companion seemed more
like a conceit of the whole Clara plot.
I know a lot of you guys want to see another
male companion, I even though Danny Pink was
going to be one until the whole Clara Romance
thing was explained.
Let me know though, if we did get a male companion,
would you care how old he is.
Like would you rather it be someone younger
like Danny Pink or do you not care.
Number 3 - The Doctor Lies
Does anyone else feel like The Doctor was
off his rocker a little?
Lying is a totally normal thing to be expected,
but the whole bit with Clara and trying to
get the next woman to die was extreme.
I loved that line, I don’t care what you
tell her, just lie and tell her I’ll save
her.
Anything to get her here.
Even though he messed with her head and took
her place it didn’t seem completely geniune.
It was like he only did that to make Clara
calm down.
His explanation at the end wasn’t much comfort
either, it was like he was telling Clara that
she should just believe what she thinks will
make her happiest.
It’s like he’s dodging the question about
whether or not he’s a good person.
It’s a bit of a cop out on his part and
I think things like that will haunt him during
the finale.
Number 2 - The Mummy is an Ancient Soldier
I liked the are you my mummy and gasmask callback
to Empty Child.
The solution to the problem was kind of rushed
in the end, but there was the whole conceit
of 66 seconds.
So I’ll give that a pass.
But now I’m wondering what War that soldier
was a part of.
It was tied to the scroll or flag or however
you want to think about it, but the only reason
it continued to drain energy from people was
because the regenerative device inside it
was malfunctioning.
I think it’s an interesting metaphor for
the Doctor, the soldier, clearly a monster,
just like the Doctor was for most of the episode,
wanted to die but could not.
He was forced to keep regenerating himself
on the energy of other people.
It’s almost like they were saying The Doctor
has been sucking the life out of Clara to
keep himself going.
That’s not the case, but I feel like it’s
in the subtext.
In reality, what I think is going on is they’re
foreshadowing the finale.
There have been liberal spoilers for what
goes on.
So please use spoiler tags if you know what
I’m talking about.
But see if you can connect these things: Dead
Soldiers unable to stop, forced to keep fighting.
And which other new character on the show
is everyone calling “The Soldier?”
Again, please use spoiler tags.
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - Clara Changes
Her Mind
So this isn’t my number 1 because it’s
awesome, it’s because it’s a major holy
crap.
I actually don’t think this is a hopeful
thing.
Something about the whole scene feels ominous.
Like Clara should have learned her lesson,
by going against Danny’s better judgement,
she’ll get smacked in the face with a terrible
situation.
It’s almost like she wasn’t listening
to The Doctor when she woke up on that planet.
He was telling her he was saving her and those
other people just happened to come along.
He wasn’t purposefully going to let them
die, but if
they had, he wouldn’t have cared that much.
Let me know what you favorite moment was,
and do you think Clara made the right choice.
I totally think this was a bad thing.
It’s gone from this place of carefree adventure
into darkness.
That’s one of the major arcs of the season,
heading into darkness.
Overall I gave the episode a B, I loved the
story concept.
An ancient soldier forced to continue fighting
a war that ended thousands of years ago, masquerading
on a mummy on one of the most famous passenger
trains in history.
The original Orient Express ran during the
late Victorian Era, which is why it looked
like they were back in victorian times.
I’m wondering if there’s any special significance
to them constantly re-visiting that period
in series 8.
They started the season there, Missy, the
main villain this year is dressed in a victorian
manner, it might just be that the producers
and set designers think that the period is
interesting from a story telling perspective.
I did like Clara and the Doctor’s outfits.
I mean I do enjoy the visual style of the
victorian era.
I did think it was a bit of a downer when
they took it all back halfway through the
episode when they revealed it was a futuristic
lab.
I would have just liked the idea of a normal
starliner designed to look like the Orient
Express.
I don’t know why they needed the added evil
scientist aspect, unless it was meant to be
something that will tie in with the finale.
We are down to the final 3 episodes.
I’m counting the last two as a two parter,
even though I think the Christmas Special
will address things from the finale.
Danny Pink has a big role in next week’s
episode, so I’m interested to see if we’ll
see any crazy twists with his character.
I will be doing a Q&A for this tomorrow.
Walking Dead is starting tomorrow night too.
Everyone in the UK will be able to watch it
within about 8 hours of people in the United
States.
So everyone check it out.
Right now click here for the Q&A, I’ll update
the annotation as soon as I post it and click
here for my episode 7 video.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you tomorrow!